ans
entraîneur angevin me entraidons c'est
un vrai plaisir pour nous de vous
accueillir ici je suis heureux de vous
présenter aux téléspectateurs monsieur
rondins directeur adjoint à la direction
voit que non ça n'est pas exactement ça
non en fait je suis directeur adjoint à
la sous direction des comités directeurs
de la direction générale
oui mais je crois que oui en fait je
sais ce que vous allez me dire je fais
fonctions de sous-directeur mais ma
direction n'est pas attachée à la même
direction
si fait que je ne dépend pas directement
de la direction on suivait je vous suis
je vous suis je vous suis très
reconnaissant de bien vouloir nous a
rien dit mais c'est la moindre des
choses pensée est très rare je vous
présente monsieur gathemo puisque trop
chefs de services d'accor pour vous
faire un facteur avec la porteuse de
pain et tu réellement mais alors essayez
de vous faire subventionner par les
boulangers mais naturellement pas
pourquoi pas oui elles auront pas
sincère avant le journal télévisé bas
nous avons déjà la pause café nous avons
la pause croûtons c'est pas plus mal
certainement voilà très bientôt enfin
servi au revoir vous et moi j'avais une
petite affaire réglée a signé vous dit
rien à nous offrir quelque chose à voir
y a du jus de pomme ah bah oui nous
sommes dans une position un peu délicate
parce que nous pourrons pas faire de la
publicité pour le jus de pomme elle se
revoir le whisky de toute façon je n'ai
pas soit noyé battant nice à vannes ont
justement monsieur monsieur che rina
ketty qui confond tout genre d'alliance
et c'est par vous qui dansait le martyre
de saint sébastien
enfin l'on pense non annoncés pas non
plus que c'est bien ce que ça vient de
chez de charmilles à germinal mais c'est
cher monsieur thiam était venu justement
pour nous poser quelques petites
questions sur les feuilletons en cour à
bois naturellement mais nous sommes là
pour ça faisait voter faut aussi des
questions naturellement nous l'avons
rien à vous cacher le cd celui-ci maison
de verre maison de verre pas tout à fait
terminée comme vous pouvez le constater
ma fait de verre quand même merci les
feuilletons je sais passionne le public
est ce que vous recevez beaucoup de
courriers et coups sûrs seulement en
moyenne compter les 1000 à 2500 athlètes
ont un jour par jour c'est ce qu'il faut
compter parle pas des lettres de
compliments la thur elle moi oui parce
que nous on prend mal
genre 8
8 10 lettres par semaine non non non
accomplie mois attend cette année plus
que ça quand même compter avec celle de
ma femme est née votre âge eux pas
compter sur notre côté 18 à 20 valais
quel dommage ou les sous les huit jours
je vais connaître tous les bijoux et
vous répondez à tous qui répondent non
non maintenant pas sur le gâteau on voit
sa photo et non mais oui je ne peux pas
répondre
ouvrez dans le placard on va vous
montrer ses montagnes de l'est a appuyé
sa prouve l'intérêt de votre mission
dites-moi est-ce qu'on pourrait en
profiter pour lire une ou deux c'est
l'être c'est tout c'est toujours la même
chose
les photons sans intérêt ça dure des
semaines et ce qu'on aime bien on ne les
voit jamais si au début de la soirée à
plusieurs reprises nous avons eu
infectant épatant on voyait un grand
monsieur sympathique assis dans un bon
fauteuil devant une table qui disait des
choses très intéressantes
parfois il enlever ses lunettes et lever
les bras au ciel je ne me souviens plus
de titres des épisodes mais je sais que
l'indicatif à la fin c'était la
marseillaise eh bien pourquoi on ne voit
pas tous les jours ce feuilleton là il
est éducatif est convenable et ça au
moins on peut le montrer aux enfants
tout cela prouve à quel point vous êtes
suivi avec intérêt avec passion même par
les téléspectateurs
mais dites moi pour faire face à tout ce
travail il vous faut des équipes
appréciable nous engageons john porter
patron tu viens de citer quelques noms
bah oui vous avez bien sûr naturellement
vous allez lagraulet cuisses et les
mollets shdm martial de la lutte que
nous voulons relier les rues molière en
juillet brière ni molière molière par
molière par molière molière mollir un
jeune garçon qui sort du lycée qui a
toujours 18 et 19 forêt aux rédactions
c'est le meilleur de sa classe des
travailleurs nous faire de très bons en
faillite parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre nos soucis nous voulons des
oeuvres propre c'est certain un peu
instructif
alors quand même pas à pas trop cher we
insist est bien là dessus quand vous en
parler c'est on ne peut pas se permettre
de faire cher
c'est pas possible mais on a vite fait
de défendre mais ça va très vite a
témoigné par exemple d'un janyk et met
le feu au jeune public connaît bien et
bien au départ elle voulait en jaguar
l'idée du vélomoteur et de moi avions
même pensé au moment du tout nous avions
même pensé à faire rouler un patin à
roulettes ou alors il fallait acheter
des parts à l'oms ont préféré j'ai
préféré prêter mon vélo moteur personnel
ils marchent bien d'ailleurs
mais il a fallu payer de l'essence tout
de même à banana et une tombola au
moment du fameux générique vous savez la
tan tan tan tan tan et tata sa g data
nous avons tourné le plan sur une
déclivité roue libre
comprenez qu'on ferait du fait accompli
est stationné sur le buvard c'est pas
une bonne idée ça je comprends qu'on
pensait c'est très habile mais dites-moi
est-ce que ces difficultés financières
ne risque pas de sclérose et votre
imagination vous avez tout de même des
projets intéressants
les projets très intéressants en
particulier nous comptons mettre en
chantier très prochainement à un
feuilleton
qui serait une grande fresque historique
ça le public adore
quelle époque choisi moi je pensais
faire une chose sur la guerre de cent
ans carrément au wifi vous n'y pensez
pas la guerre de cent ans toyer grand
vous savez vous vous rendez compte 26
épisodes fait quatre années en un quart
d'heure nom propre richie ou alors ou
alors la eagle la cab et 30 ans qu'en
pensez vous c'est pas une mauvaise car
oui oui je comprends bien il ne faut pas
de figuration considérable de grands
décors mais quel est le poids limite est
ce que par exemple vous pourriez faire
un feuilleton avec la pièce de
pirandello six personnages en quête
d'auteur non encore trop non à la
réunion ce qu'on pourrait faire sont les
captent sergent de la rochelle manon peu
les potes cinq provinces le tournage
oui il ya les extérieurs ben oui j'ai
belge c'est bien mais c'est pas facile
non plus il ya les trois mousquetaires
ou retombent très bien qu'ils sont aux
quatre à bas je pense jamais à l'autre
bien sûr oui oui où les deux orphelines
bah pareil elles retrouvent leurs
familles à la phase possible ça fait du
monde
comprenez moi je moi je je pense à un
truc qui pourrait être bon jeu serait
carrément le les rêveries d'un promeneur
solitaire à celle qui sait
les rêveries d'un 7 sur la conso pas de
droit d'auteur trop important un pays il
est mort ya deux siècles
ah bon peut-être des directions alors il
mettait ses enfants à l'assistance
publique va très bien et ne fait pas
bien c'est une oeuvre qui vous intéresse
je t'ai pas tendu enfin un projet
satisfaisant
une oeuvre classique qui ne coûtent pas
cher monsieur voilà voilà ce que nous
cherchons temps et que nous trouvons si
rarement la culture a lié à l'économie
comprenez vous et bien je vous remercie
monsieur des indications si important à